well saquon barkley entering year three
one of the great running backs in the
nfl although the giants mired at number
29 on the preseason power rankings and
they deserve it this one was stunning to
me
the giants have the worst record in the
nfl over the past three seasons at 12
and 36
and that includes the browns going oh
and 16 and the giants are still the
worst team on a three-year cumulative
record in the nfl that is an
embarrassment for your favorite team it
is that hurts my heart uh but i i do
believe this i i do think they've turned
the corner here and there's things to be
excited about with the new york giants
team first off yeah you know the more
time that's gone on i've been more and
more impressed with the things i've read
and seen the joe judge i'm a believer in
the coaches they hired there joe judge
the coach jason garrett the offensive
coordinator patrick graham who i worked
with in new england as the defensive
coordinator they're they're men and
people i believe in and i and i do think
they're really damn good coaches so it's
unfortunate they haven't been able to
coach yet but um uh i do think that
they're going in the right direction
well let's see what these damn good
coaches can do in a division that is
among the weakest in the nfl over under
win total for 2020 with joe judge in his
first season as head coach six and a
half will you dare to go over i i really
want to go over i i think this is a team
that can surprise people you know for
for a few reasons right i mean
first off they got a lot of big people
you know dave gettleman it's a love-hate
relationship with me and him as a giants
fan all right it's like you with kirk
cousins like some days i love him some
days i love him not um and as far as
like big people up front offense and
defensive line they're nobody's gonna
push the new york giants around they got
more big people than any team in
football maybe other than the baltimore
ravens so it's gonna give them a chance
and of course i like some of their stars
so i guess if you're gonna put a gun to
my head i'm probably gonna go under at
like six though that's i i really think
this can be a seven and nine type
football team
well okay so
you're going under
yes because i think six and ten would be
an improvement and it would be a good
season for the giants and maybe they
could be better than that but that
that's why over under sometimes are
vexing because you pick the right number
and you don't know which way to flip
right but i'll say under as well i i
don't know how good washington's going
to be
uh i i look i just philadelphia and
dallas philadelphia players can't stay
healthy they're going to be clustered
around eight and eight the cowboys
around eight and eight weren't they all
nobody was better than eight and eight
last year right what did the eagles go
nine and seven eight or nine and seven
nine and seven oh yeah nine and seven
and they're the only team in the
division that's kept their staff the
same so they have an advantage there
that's what you know to me when i look
at the giants that hurts you mean joe
judge trying to implement the new
england ways the new england system
patrick graham trying to you know
install the bill belichick defense you
know that's going to be tough i mean
there's a lot of rules as we've talked
about there and and the fact that they
haven't been able to be with the players
and implement this new program and
system is is going to make it harder on
them
all right you mentioned your love hate
relationship with gm dave gutterman over
under on years left on the job one and a
half oh
man um
i think there's a way it sits right now
because he is not loved here in the new
york area as of right now
it's gonna depend on this year i'm gonna
go over i'm gonna say he gets two more
years i am i'm gonna say at the very
least he gets that i think the giants
are gonna perform a little bit better
and be a little more competitive than
people realize this year i think that
does him some justice and maybe buys him
at least another year
now this is a guy who did build a super
bowl team right in carolina he inherited
cam newton uh in all fairness the most
important player on that 2015 team that
made it to the super bowl and and gave
the broncos a run for their money i i am
going to say over
because it has to be over you can't
change your gm
after changing your coach you can't that
too many of these teams are on this
weird track where we fire one or the
other and do these teams not realize
that it's so much better to have shared
accountability right they either both
stay or they both go and if that's the
atmosphere you develop in your
organization what happens is when things
start to fall apart
the coach doesn't have to worry about
the gm whispering to the owner about how
badly the coach is doing the gm doesn't
have to worry about the coach going to
see the owner to complain about the gm
because the coach and the gm recognize
we either both stay or we both go so we
better work together why do teams not
realize that that's the easiest way to
avoid a dysfunctional organization you
can't let the coach think he can win a
power struggle with the gm you can't let
the gm think he can win a power struggle
with the coach and what do we have in
new york over the past several years you
got this revolving door and the worst
thing they could do because they're not
going to fire joe judge after one year
the worst thing they could do is hire a
gm
other than dave gettleman because the gm
is going to be immediately thinking how
do i get that coach that i've always
said would be the guy i hire if i become
a gm i mean mike you're you're right
there's no doubt i mean there's just a
lot of franchises in football who don't
get that and don't understand that
that's what makes the really good team
successful you know look the teams that
we like seem to talk about it on a
yearly basis have a lot of the things
you're talking about whether it's the
patriots the ravens you know the
steelers i know the steelers aren't in
the super bowl but they're always
relevant and a good football team it's
all that same conversation you're
talking about i do think
that there is some potential for this
relationship to be good though between
gettlemen you know gentlemen boston guy
in your face
you know what you see is what you get
real football guy and i think he's got
you know coaches that are similar to
that joe judge a philadelphia guy who's
in your face worked for belichick nick
saban he's not going to hold any punches
and like i said the two coordinators are
the same way too so i think this is
where because joe judge and patrick
graham and jason garrett's been a head
coach i think they're going to really
help out dave gettleman ultimately
because i think they're going to also
help him and give him a vision of what
they want in their systems and
ultimately that's what you're talking
about and that's where good gms and
teams work out bill belichick and nick
casario work out cause nick casario up
there in new england knows how bill's
thinking he knows what he's looking for
at every position on the field oh wait
you know we like our defensive tackles
like this we like our linebackers like
this and that's why it works i think
there's a good good possibility that
could work here and gettleman i don't
think is too egotistical to like
overpower everybody and do that that way
he'll listen and want to build a team
and i think honestly he wants to build
big physical teams and these are coaches
that come from the big physical school
of coaching type teams as well and i
think that's why that marriage has a
chance to work
one more before we take a break we
haven't mentioned it today we've talked
about it in the past jason garrett is
the offensive coordinator and you got a
lot of fans who roll their eyes and
groan at the prospect of jason garrett
running the offense but one of his
biggest flaws as head coach in dallas
was he couldn't do both simultaneously
but he'd proven he can be a good
offensive coordinator and if you bring
that dallas approach with daniel jones
and saquon barkley and the weapons they
have ingram right yeah they they could
you know the
so over under 17th in the nfl in total
yards per game are you putting them in
the top half of the league or the bottom
half i'm putting them in over i am you
know i worry about the giants defense
the secondary coverage offensively i
think there's a chance for some you know
we talked about some of the names i
think daniel jones has superstar
potential saquon's a superstar like you
said evan ingram if he can stay freaking
healthy is one of those george kittle
special type tight ends too and then
darius slayton last year as a rookie and
then of course let's not forget sterling
shepherd and golden tate so there's
something there on the offensive side of
the ball with a good system and a
quarterback who's going into year two
who was very impressive in year one to
where i think definitely they can be in
the top half of football on offense
last year the cowboys were number one in
the nfl in yards per game with jason
garrett as the head coach
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports